[Music]
william
is with us in pensacola florida hi
william how are you
doing fantastic sir thank you for asking
sure how about yourself
uh yes uh so i had a quick question for
you uh much the similar
um as the same caller in her
living situation uh after taxes i don't
make much more than minimum wage
and i've been carrying the car loan that
i have now for
a little over two years my question was
is it
worth refinancing the vehicle uh to try
and free up some extra money so
i can afford a place to live by myself
and not live with my parents anymore
or what's the best course of action
how much do you own your car yeah
what is that how much do you owe on your
car
i have 13 000 left what kind of car is
it will you
it's a 2017 ford focus
okay um and how old are you
i'm 26 in march okay and
why um tell me about your career because
it sounds like you have an income
problem
yes sir i don't have much of a career at
the moment i fell in some hard times
and troubled upbringing so i'm just
really just trying to overcome a lot of
that and start making
my own efforts to to get into a career
now
what what what's preventing you from
getting a solid job
i know you said hard times but like
without saying too much of the personal
information what's what's preventing you
from getting a good quality job
uh probably experience okay do you have
any education
i'm self-taught so it's not viewed the
same
but i have enough of a generalized
understanding
and what do you probably take what are
you doing right now william for a career
i'm working in a college uh basically
enter grades
okay okay all right uh here's my thing
i agree with dave you have an income
problem and you're young
and so uh i think right now until you
can land a solid career and i want to
connect you with our career expert ken
coleman
but before you go over there there are
two practical things you could be doing
right now you have a 2017
car quality car and just the other day
on the show we found
uh dr john delonay and ourselves met a
young man your age
uh making about six thousand dollars a
month just off of delivering
uh for ubereats and for just doing uber
period
and so your income problem could be
fixed
if you're willing to really put into
work and so if i was you with a 2017
car right now immediately when i hang up
the phone i'm registering with uber
you're in florida which is wide open i
will start driving people around on top
of what you're doing
then get connected with ken coleman to
figure out what is your sweet spot how
can you get into a career
that will set you up to win but right
now you don't even have the money to
move out with your parents you got 13
000
in debt so we need to get your income up
and then your first priority yes
is to get out on your own and then we
need to talk about how do we get you out
of this debt and don't rack up any more
debt but today
immediately william i need you to kind
of like
say this respectfully step up it's time
for you to become the young man that you
are
and going ahead get on an uber find you
something you can do today that can
start generating you an
extra five thousand dollars a week
immediately
yeah um i don't know what you've been
facing with your hard times i can't i
you know obviously we don't have that
information but
the answer to your question is you only
owe 13 000
on the car if you told me it was 33 000
and you're making minimum wage i would
have said just sell the car yeah
this is selling this car does not fix
your situation
because it's not really your problem the
fact that it's pinching you
is indic is because of your income
more than it's because of the debt or
the size of the car payment
that kind of a thing and so yeah your
issue is
career short term and long term and
we've got to get your income up short
term and anthony outlined that for you
and then long term so
hang on and um kelly will pick up and
we'll get you hooked up with
a ken coleman book the proximity
principal and she can also
set you on his website and help you with
some of the uh
some of the interview techniques and
some of the things that he's teaching
which are absolutely fabulous
dave you're a father and i just got to
ask you this question because i'm seeing
this more and more with this younger
generation
they're at home they don't have a good
job
and i feel as if part of that is and a
huge part of that is on
the the young man or the young lady but
would you agree or disagree with me that
a huge part of that also is on the
parent
you're allowing your son or daughter to
come home to be 26 27 30 years old
making 30 000 a year like how is that
advancing them forward
well it yeah i mean mom and dad's
attitude
about the whole thing affects the young
person's attitude as well
so if mom and dad are like well you know
pandemic and it's bad
out there and there's no jobs and
you know they got a negative attitude
about everything they don't see any
positive way to go make money um and you
know oh you can't do uber because you
know
you can't be socially distanced or you
can't have enough masks on or
whatever i don't i don't know what it i
mean but if mom and dad are saying
well i mean you're screwed you can't do
anything so you might as well live at
home instead of saying
uh you step up man up here and let's get
going which is what you did
to with this guy and and so it's um
you know i grew up one of the blessings
of the household i grew up in was mom
and dad were entrepreneurial
and so if um if you didn't have any
money it's just because
you didn't have any ideas and you
weren't working so you need an idea
and you get to work on it because
there's always a way to make money
i mean you can walk dogs you can mow
lawns you can clean out gutters you can
pressure wash driveways
you can you know i mean teenage jobs i
have done i've shoveled out stuff out of
houses i don't even want to think about
and so i mean there's all you know it's
there's
and you'd be amazed what people will pay
you to do if you will bother go get you
a leaf blower rich people are afraid of
leaves you know
i mean it's it's uh you know there's a
lot of stuff that people can do but but
mom and dad my parents had that
entrepreneurial spirit and so we weren't
a we weren't allowed to not work yes and
b we weren't allowed to not be
dreaming about a better life while we
were working
that's good and instead of just like
well the little man can't get ahead
you're just stuck the pandemics got you
in
this generation here you just can't get
anything and you're just
bad now god man when i was your age
there's lots of opportunities you guys
ain't got any opportunities there's
nothing out there to do
and good lord with technology right now
you can start about six businesses by
nightfall yes
yes yes yes and when i hear that dave i
i get so frustrated and i have to ask
you because
well i think most parents are between
you know they're between hard driving
entrepreneurs like mine were
and you know eeyore that i just painted
up right so
they're somewhere between and but i
think the thing mom and dad can do is
speak
life over the situation speak blessings
over the situation
and it's not false encouragement or
false positive thinking or something
like that
that you just dream up it's just really
believing that if you
you know you get out there and you push
things around something will fall over
yeah but i'll guarantee you it won't
while you're sitting there wishing it
was going to
yeah yeah parents we got to do better i
mean i'm not a parent so i can't speak
to
a parent as a parent but i would
definitely say i i am
concerned uh with this generation
a small portion of this generation and i
get it covet happened
covet was real jobs were real but dave
i've seen so many young people got
creative they went online
they started online tutoring they went
out there starting cutting people's
grass because they were scared to go
outside
and just last week me and john was so
shocked on friday
this young kid 28 years old said man
yeah i made six thousand dollars
just from doing uber driving people
around and i'm like wow and people are
saying there's there's no way
to make money right now and there is if
you're willing to put into work
you will do it we want you safe we're
not saying do not be safe
but at the same time when you step up
and say you know what i'm going to take
control over my future
and i'm going to become better every
single day and you can
yeah well and it's you know lou holt's
our buddies 83 and
what he said when he was down here last
summer speaking he said uh
please don't keep me alive by stopping
me from living